wir stehen hier wo diese krassen bilder
entstanden sind vor dem santa maria
krankenhaus das ist das
universitätsklinikum hier in lissabon
waren den ganzen tag schon die unterwegs
und im hintergrund können wir dieses
gelbe zelt sehen dort kommen die
krankenwagen die hier den ganzen tag ein
und ausfahren über die straße von dort
vorne anfahren dann an zu dem gelben
zelt hin und dort werden wellen ärzte
aus ok dieser patientin geht es jetzt so
schlecht dass er noch hier ins
krankenhaus kann und/oder dieser
patienten geht es noch gut genug der
wirt weitergeschickt werden dann hier
weggeschickt meistens zu anderen
krankenhäusern und deswegen hat sich
jetzt seit freitag als diese kassen
bilder mit den vielen wartenden
krankenwagen entstanden sind die lager
sich ein bisschen beruhigt die
krankenwagen standen hier in der langen
reihe dort in richtung krankenhaus
mittlerweile stehen dort immer noch so
um die 45 krankenwagen in den corona
patienten liegen die darauf warten dass
sie in die corinna stationen hinein
dürfen
sie müssen dort aber lange zeit warten
plön wurde mal einer aus einem
krankenwagen herausgeholt und das ist
hier eine wirklich sehr sehr gruselige
stimmung war den ganzen tag in lissabon
unterwegs diese stadt die sonst
eigentlich so belebt so fröhlich so
offen für ihre offenheit eben bekannt
ist ist ja runter gefahren die menschen
müssen zu hause bleiben
es ist komplett still menschen dürfen
nur noch zur arbeit fahren und dazu dann
halt eben an diesem 17 jahre alten
krankenhaus das ja sehr sehr an sich
schon gruselig aussieht stehen hier
diese krankenwagen mit menschen die
teilweise dort mit der mit der schweren
krankheit krone kämpfen und um ihr leben
kämpfen warten in diesen krankenwagen
dass sie überhaupt man ja aufgenommen
werden können weil es eben keine betten
mehr gibt das sind bilder die wir zum
glück in deutschland so noch nicht sehen
wenngleich natürlich auch bei uns die
krankenhäuser unter volllast echten seit
einigen wochen oder monaten peter sack
uns wie hat sich diese lage in portugal
so dramatisch verändert ich war im
sommer selbst noch da da war völliger
entspannung in
portugal da war man sehr sehr
diszipliniert aber warm war eben auch
stolz darauf dass die zahlen so weit
unten waren jetzt sind die explodiert
was sagen dir die portugiesen dort warum
ist das passiert ja die portugiesen
haben vor allen dingen zwei gründe
ausgemacht dafür dass das jetzt hier so
schnell explodiert ist portugal war ja
lange zeit ein vorzeigeland eigentlich
in europa hatte niedrigere zahlen
doch dann insbesondere an weihnachten
sind die zahlen ausgebauten portugiesen
machen dafür eben zwei gründe aus
einerseits zeigen sie mit dem finger auf
die briten die so hat die aussage vieler
portugiesen als es in großbritannien mit
der mutation immer schlimmer wurde
weiter nach portugal geflogen sind viele
briten sind ja hier mit portugal eng
verbunden aber auch viele portugiesen
arbeiten in großbritannien da wird der
eine grund für diesen plötzlichen
ausbruch ausgemacht weil ja gerade die
britische mutation hier in portugal sehr
stark kassiert der andere grund stehen
uns auf viele portugiesen genannt haben
den sehen sie bei sich selbst die schuld
das sehen sie bei sich selbst schuld
nämlich portugal ist ein streng
katholisches land und deswegen haben die
portugiesen das weihnachtsfest fast so
wie jedes jahr ganz normal gefeiert und
das hat halt in der meinung nach von
vielen portugiesen dazu geführt dass die
zahlen ebenso explodiert der explodiert
sind
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren